the main problem with war is not that
people get killed it's that people have
to live with total uncertainty and
craziness and that's incompatible with
what people want Tucker Carlson went on
the all-in podcast you know the all-in
podcast my friend David saaks is one of
the co-hosts over there uh and uh Tucker
talked about how Nome represents the
exact type of fascism that we better be
watching out for I also think that once
you decide that like hey let's just go
crazy
and you couple that with true social
disorder like you get to a place where
you can't buy anything at CVS cuz it's
chained up because shoplifting has been
legalized as it has been in California
what you're going to get is fascism
because people can't live in in that in
they can't live with chaos like that's
the one thing they can't deal with and
I've covered a couple of wars and that
was my main conclusion the main problem
with war is not that people get killed
it's that people have to live with total
uncertainty and craziness and that's
incompat ible with what people want like
that's the that's the worst thing you
know we're all going to die dying is not
the worst thing the worst thing is
living in chaos and we're starting to
live in chaos and so the return to order
is what scares me I think it'd be very
easy and I do think Gavin Newsome is a
fascist I think he's the kind of person
who would have no problem no hesitation
about using the doj to C to imprison his
political opponents now Biden is
imprisoning his political opponents but
at least they're lying about it Gavin
Newsome is the kind of person who be
like well yeah you're you're aat to the
general order and you're going to jail
and I think because we're in a moment of
chaos right now people kind of want that
actually I think one of the purposes of
degrading and confusing our society is
to make way for authoritarianism even
more than we have now um so that kind of
freaks me out yeah all right Tucker's
making a really deep point there when
you see the chaos on our streets and
we're going to get to some of that in
just a moment when you see what's
happening in New York City and San
Francisco in Portland and that they can
jump the turn Styles as you know and
they can steal all the stuff from the
drug stores and you can steal a
PlayStation 5 and four games as long as
it's under $900 from Best Buy and all of
those things the chaos the utter chaos
when they just take over the streets and
you can't go over that bridge because
we're protesting for a terrorist group
across the world and all of those things
the chaos only lasts for so long because
people cannot functionally deal with
that over time and eventually you can
feel it can't you feel it that they
would be glad to usher in authoritarian
society and I really believe that that's
what Gavin Nome was testing out when he
brought XI jingping in and he suddenly
said see I can clean up the streets I
can do it because the Communist dictator
is here and look what I could do and the
homeless people magically disappeared
and he had his fences up and it was
clean and they power washed the off the
streets and everything else and then of
course Xi Jinping leaves all hell breaks
loose again that's what's happening on
the streets again because eventually
over time Tucker's right people don't
ask that that much we don't ask that
much we're so distracted with our phones
and video games and whatever the
nonsense of the day is all of modernity
has left us kind of
inept right like we don't ask for much
we're just kind of blobs out there and
we'll just take whatever they give us
but at some point when your city is
endlessly burning and you can't go into
stores anymore and all of those things
then you might demand a real
authoritarian leader to clean it
up